Ben Laden s'appuie sur une organisation
l'organisation Al-Qaïda qui l'a mis en
place il y a 13 ans je vous propose de
voir comment elle fonctionne
Al-Qaïda la base en langue arabe
Oussama Ben Laden a créé cette
organisation en 1988 en Afghanistan
voici la face visible de cette structure
des camps d'entraînement
derrière le reste est informé presque
insaisissable
première action significative un
attentat contre le World Trade Center en
1998 attentat contre les ambassades
américaines du Kenya et de Tanzanie
entre ces deux dates les techniques les
moyens des terroristes ont
considérablement progressé une science
d'humeur sous toutes ses formes kalkaïda
a même fait imprimer en 11 volumes
Al-Qaïda ne revendique jamais aucun acte
mais les enquêtes montent toujours sur
ses chefs l'état-major d'Oussama Ben
Laden
pour les opérations militaires Mohamed
hatef chèque tacir chargé de la sécurité
chaque Saïd lui tient les finances le
quatrième année et l'idéologue pour les
services de renseignement c'est aussi le
plus dangereux on le retrouve dès 1981
parmi les militants égyptiens arrêtés
après l'assassinat de Saddad
déjà c'est lui le plus véhément en 86 il
quitte l'Égypte depuis rien aucune
information fiable sur cet ancien
chirurgien toujours dans l'ombre de Ben
Laden ce serait le cerveau utilisant le
milliardaire saoudien comme un symbole
une vitrine pour les fanatiques